was an active member of the journalists
Association in Pokhara news of his death
in a plane crash on Sunday has shocked
many in the community friends and
colleagues gathered near the Sethi River
to pay their respects
we've lost family a friend a colleague
Nepal has lost someone with so much
potential and possibility
was a father and husband relatives
collected his body on Tuesday teams have
spent days searching the crash site to
retrieve the victim's Remains the Army
has airlifted 48 bodies to the capital
Kathmandu for identification the city
has more forensic facilities the bodies
of the crew members and foreign
Nationals on board are among them we're
outside the hospital Morgan Pokhara
where the postmortem of 22 passengers
from in and around the area is being
conducted as more bodies are released it
will provide much needed relief to
grieving families Krishna bhature has
lost his sister-in-law and two
granddaughters they were traveling to
Pokhara to celebrate a local Festival
they found my granddaughters early on
but couldn't find my sister-in-law
finally we heard about her last evening
after what seems like an endless wait
he's relieved their bodies have been
recovered now he says he can lay them to
rest in proper family tradition
Al Jazeera in Pokhara Nepal